[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire pour
faciliter l'accès des chasseurs au
munition notamment en zone rural
certains bureaux de tabac seront
autorisés à vendre des munitions une une
décision du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
laisse les armuriers sceptiques comme
l'a constaté vos télévision dans un
instant à l'approche des fêes celle du
périgor sont les plus connus mais à
trois le marché au truf propose une
production locale issue de Bourgogne et
de la Meuse en son temps ce sont ces
truffes qui avaient les honneurs de la
table des rois de France Canal 32 nous
fera découvrir ce champignon magique au
goût de noisette au man le passage vient
d'ouvrir ses portes et ses cuisines un
lieu où les personnes qui souffrent
d'isolement social peuvent venir
préparer un repas une équipe de LM TV
Sart a partagé ce moment de convivialité
autour d'une table à l'approche de Noël
et puis notre partenaire TL7 dans la
Loire nous emmènera la découverte de la
crèche de Nadine passionné de santon
depuis de nombreuses années une
tradition familiale que cette mère de
famille perpétue avec ses enfants sur
plus de 10 m carré installé au milieu du
salon à partir du 1er janvier il sera
possible acheter des cartouches dans les
bureaux de tabac pas seulement des
cartouches de cigarettes mais bien des
munitions pour les fusils de chasse une
annonce faite récemment par le ministère
de l'Intérieur pour faciliter l'accès
des chasseurs aux munitions notamment
dans les zones rurales vous allez le
voir une décision qui n'enchante pas les
armurier comme l'a constaté notre
partenaire vuge télévision sur
place la nouvelle a pu en désarmer plus
d'un car c'est vrai qu'on pouvait déjà y
acheter des cartouches de cigarettes on
devrait dès le 1er janvier prochain s'y
procurer des cartouches pour la chasse
annonce faite récemment par le ministère
de l'Intérieur pour faciliter l'accès
des chasseurs aux munitions notamment en
zone rurale mais pas seulement et sous
certaines conditions dans cette
armurerie qui a pignon sur rue depuis
1966 sur Épinal on est pour le moins
sceptique sur cette mesure c'est vrai
que nous on demande quand même beaucoup
de sécurité beaucoup de choses comme ça
et là on veut donner un accès plus
facile donc il faudra voir sous quelle
modalité quelle réglementation il va
falloir appliquer on a encore pas les
points précis ça va faire un plus dans
notre diversification qui est déjà
importante puisque nous réalisons
beaucoup de d'activités annexe à la
vente du tabac
notamment le le compte nickel les relais
colis la presse la confiserie euh le
paiement de proximité nous nous sommes
devenus des commerces d'utilité
locale ils sont 153 buralistes dans les
vauges dont 30 % exerc dans des communes
de moins de 3500 habitants une mesure
qui nécessitera un certain nombre de
conditions il y aura un encadrement très
strict à cette vente et que il y aura
aussi une formation à réaliser sur de
jours de temps et après ce sera soumis à
l'appréciation du préfet du département
les profession concerné attendent pour
leheur davantage de précision sur la
mise en uvre de cette mesure qui
concernerait donc les munitions de
catégorie C et D réservé à la chasse et
imagine notre armurier spinalien au tir
sportif
sans aucune transition je vous propose
de nous rendre à Grenoble en quelques
années la capitale des Alpes est devenue
l'une des capitales françaises du vélo
en 2022 Grenoble était d'ailleurs
désigné première ville cyclable de
France pour les trajets domiciles
travail suite logique de cet engagement
la ville vient d'inaugurer la première
école du vélo en France une école pour
apprendre à circuler à vélo en ville en
toute sécurité pour télégrenobl camavon
nous emmène à
bicyclette s'arrêter à un stop indiqué
sa direction ou encore apprendre à
entretenir son vélo c'est l'objectif de
l'école du vélo ici à l'anneau de
vitesse du parc Paul Mistral à Grenoble
les enfants enfilent leur chasse du bleu
jaune et testent les différents parcours
d'apprentissage un coup de en
plus pour la capitale française du vélo
c'était une de nos décisions sur le
bouclier social et climatique que nous
avons mis en place grâce aux impôts
supplémentaires qui sont levé et
demander c'est une contribution
importante mais c'est une des
manifestations là de une traduction de
ce bouclier sociale et climatique parce
que évidemment nous sommes maintenant
reconnus comme la capitale française du
vélo depuis 3 ans mais nous regardons là
où nous pourrions être et donc nous
regardons des villes comme Amsterdam ou
copenhag en disant la pratique du vélo a
doublé à Grenoble l'objectif est de
former 100 % des écoliers grenoblois
pour qu'ils soi capable de rouler en
autonomie sur les routes avant leur 12
ans mais l'école du vélo n'est pas
uniquement réservée aux enfants elle
s'adresse aussi aux adultes qui
voudraient se remettre en selle ou alors
à ceux qui veulent apprendre en faire
nous avons constaté que une forte
demande notamment des personnes des
femmes des su de quartier qui voudraient
apprendre à faire des vélos pour pouvoir
partir avec leurs enfants dans
différents lieux et pouvoir faire des
sorties avec eux pour promouvoir cette
pratique Nathalie Bayon professionnelle
dans la course de vélo longue distance
et Aurélien Fontenois Champion du Monde
de Trial un sport de franchissement
d'obstacles de toutes sortes d'obstacles
sont les ambassadeurs de l'école un rôle
qui leur tient à cœur j'étais très
honoré de d'être voilà choisi pour ce
rôle et ça me fait très plaisir moi je
j'ai vraiment envie de promouvoir le
vélo et la pratique pour tout le monde
installé sous les gradins de l'anneau de
vitesse l'école du vélo a pour ambition
de devenir un lieu de référence pour
s'informer sur cette pratique mais
également un lieu de rencontre entre
association et amateurs le coût du
fonctionnement de cette école devrait
s'élever à près de 300000 € par an je
vous le disais dans les titres de ce
journal télévisé son parfum est plus
intense que celui de sa cousine du
périgor mais en raison de la sécheresse
elle était absente des marchés l'an
passé la pluie et les orages de l'été
ont été bénéfique au diamant noir
bourguignon notre partenaire Canal 32 a
parcouru les étales du marché de TR
regardez tuber unsinatum ce nom ne vous
dit peut-être rien pourtant vous
connaissez sûrement ce champignon vendu
à prix d'or la truff de Bourgogne aussi
appelé truff d'automne est un produit de
luxe cultivé dans le sud de la France
mais aussi dans l'Aube comme ici du côté
de braselogne Beauvoir allez viens vite
c'est bien allez donne voilà c'est bien
notre truff de Bourgogne pousse dans des
environnements ombragés plutôt dens on
essaie de gérer cette densité parce
qu'il faut quand même un peu de lumière
il faut pas que ce soit trop trop sombre
mais il faut quand même que ce soit
sombre accompagné de Maya et fripouille
Éric récolte les truffes pour ensuite
les vendre à des restaurateurs ou des
particuliers la culture de l'or noir
demande de la patience la Truffière
d'Éric a aujourd'hui 2 4 ans
j'ai trouvé ma première truff au bout de
8 ans mais j'ai passé 2 ans sans rien
trouver derrière meilleure année en
terme de de production ça a été 2014 si
on prend le profil climatique de 2014 si
on regarde la pluviométrie les
températures et tout ça ça a été une
année très équilibrée quoi dans l'Aube
moins d'une tonne de truffes est récolté
par an l'association haoise des truffes
d'automne travaille toute l'année à la
conservation et à la valorisation de ce
champignon en 1869 chattin un historien
de la truff avec évalué que l'aube avait
un potentiel truffié de 6000 kg 6 tonnes
mais après il y a eu la guerre de 14 la
guerre de 40 qui fait que le biotope de
la truffe d'automne a été perturbé pour
démocratiser la truffe des rois
l'association organise depuis 4 ans un
marché où il est possible d'acheter des
truffes ou juste de les déguster 2021 il
y a eu 20 kg qui ont qui sont partis
dans la matiné l'an dernier il eu 9 kg
cette année on a 6 ou se vendeurs qui
vont venir C chefs de cuisine qui qui
nous prépare des des amus bouche des
mises en bouche à base de truff le
rendez-vous est donné à 3 au sellers
Saint-Pierre pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir la truffe de
champagne cette semaine le Tour de
France du travail pénitentiaire faisait
étape à la prison de veesin près de
Rennes la prison cherche de nouveaux
marchés pour les détenus les employeurs
ont besoin de main d'œuvre de nouveaux
liens sont donc à imaginer et une
trentaine de chefs d'entreprise sont
venus découvrir les ateliers de
production du site c'est un reportage de
Natacha Astor pour TVR à Rennes hormis
les grilles c'est un atelier de
production comme un autre au centre
pénitentiaire de Vezin jusqu'à 100
détenus sur les 800 peuvent avoir un
travail l'objectif favoriser la
réinsertion et éviter la récidive Franck
a acquis de nouvelles compétences il est
même devenu contrôleur de fin de ligne
être enfermé 22h sur 24 c'est pas
motivant bah ça permet de travailler de
8h à 13h30 donc de m'évader de la
cellule de voir autre chose et de
pouvoir me réinsérer après une fois que
ma peine sera finie de voir des patrons
ça permet de de se rebooster et de dire
en même temps n'oubliez pas je suis là
si vous avez besoin de moi de 8h à 13h30
et payer 5,18 brut de l'heure les
détenus assemblent conditionnent
rénovent pour cantiner payer les parties
civiles ou pour une remise de peine les
motivations sont variées et 70 d'entre
eux sont sur liste d'attente la prison
de Vezin travaille avec C clients
réguliers on a cœur de mettre en avant
notre savoir-faire on est aussi en
recherche d'un nouveau partenaire à
savoir qu'effectivement le travail en
prison est peu connu ce que nous
recherchons aussi comme partenaire c'est
de faire de l'assemblage mécanique voilà
sur des opérations qui seraient à forte
valeur plus forte valeur ajoutée que du
conditionnement plusieurs entreprises
étaient convié pour visiter la prison et
se renseigner on se rend compte que
finalement beaucoup plus de choses sont
réalisables que ce qu'on pensait que le
ministère est aussi prêt à accompagner
les entreprises dans l'installation
d'ateliers en effet le ministère de la
justice a lancé cette année le Tour de
France du travail pénitentiaire avec
pour objectif d'atteindre les 50 % de
détenus en contrat contre 31 %
actuellement face au vieillissement de
la population de nouvelles initiatives
voient le jour afin d'entretenir la
mobilité des personnes âgées de
nouvelles structures qui s'apparentent à
des aires de jeu pour enfants se
développent dans le sud de la France
Olivier Michel pour via Occitanie a
tester celle installée à Alès dans le
gare la structure a tout d'un air de jeu
pour enfants à laquelle il ne manquerait
que le toboggan en réalité il s'agit là
d'un parcours santé pour senior et c'est
bien ça ça fait une un petit exercice en
plus de notre gymnastique au début je
croyais que c'était pour les gamins
parce que vu la hauteur tout ça et et en
fin de compte quand je l'essayé j'ai vu
que c'était dur et c'était bien pour les
adultes la structure a un objectif
simple maintenir une activité physique
et lutter contre la perte de mobilité
alors il travaille les bras les jambes
les poignets les les doigts le fait de
rester stable tous ces éléments
d'équilibre qui ont un vrai plus pour la
motricité et pour rester en bonne santé
derrière ce produit conçu par des ergo
et kinésithérapeut une société
finlandaise elle a lancé en l'an 2000
une gamme senior qui s'est démocratisé
en France dans les épades en 2010 et
gagne aujourd'hui les collectivités
c'est des équipements qui permettent de
reproduire des gestes au quotidiens de
des seniors euh type un escalier bouger
le bras pour pour aller chercher une
catolle en hauteur par exemple et euh
donc les les clinés se servent de ces
modules pour reproduire ses gestes au
quotidien l'exercice extérieur est très
bon certes pour pour pour le corps mais
également pour tout tout ce qui est
cérébral des bénéfices physiques et
d'autres induits car qui dit perte de
mobilité dit moins de sortie et donc
isolement et risque de désociabilisation
coût de la structure 22000 €
judicieusement implanté devant une école
elle peut être utilisée par tous
histoire de favoriser également le lien
social et
intergénérationnel il y a 7 ans
Jean-Claude marché apprenait de son
médecin être atteint d'un cancer du
pancréas un cancer difficile à traiter
prise en charge au centre hospitalier
universitaire de Bordeaux Jean-Claude
n'a jamais rien abandonné à la maladie
même s'il sait qu'il ne la vaincra pas
il y a quelques jours entouré du
personnel soignant auquel il ne manque
pas de rendre hommage il a fêté avec
humour et un gâteau sa 125e séance de
chimiothérapie oui vous avez bien
entendu 125 séances un record qui
mériterait presque le guinnessbook mais
qui dit beaucoup de l'avancée de la
médecine et de l'importance de la
motivation et de la résilience dans la
lutte contre cette maladie la 125e cion
se fait évidemment avec un gâteau c'est
vraiment le gâteau je vais dire de
l'amour que que qui a et qu'on échange
ici avec la bienveillance les soins et
je vrais encore dire à tous ceux qui
sont malades qu'une situation n'est
jamais désespérée et bien sûr ça va bien
un
gâteau l' exemple de JeanClaude marché
montre l'importance de la prise en
charge médicale or sur l'ensemble du
territoire 5 millions de Français n'ont
pas de médecins traitants c'est aussi le
cas en Martinique comme ici à
grandrivivière depuis la ferme du
dispensaire il y a 20 ans les habitants
doivent parcourir de nombreux kilomètres
pour se faire soigner pour le plus grand
soulagement de la population un médecin
retraité depuis 6 ans par solidarité a
accepté de reprendre du service pour
lutter contre ce désert médical c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué à Daan François udoxy
pour via TV sur place nous nous trouvons
dans la salle d'accueil des patients
c'est dans ce local que sera installé le
nouveau et le seul cabinet médical de
grandrivivière retraité depuis près de 6
ans c'est le docteur Claude petit qui
assurera les consultations une fois par
semaine j'ai accepté ce challenge de me
remettre au travail pour permettre à
cette charmante commune de pouvoir
trouver une solution à ce désert médical
auquel la population est confrontée
depuis trop longtemps une bonne nouvelle
annoncée à l'occasion de la fête
patronale dans cette commune d'environ
650 habit
tous dev se démener pour se faire
soigner depuis la fermeture d'un
dispensaire il y a près d'une vingtaine
d'années l'arrivée d'un médecin dans la
commune est un soulagement on l'attend
comme le mess je peux vous dire qu'on
est ravi on allit
sur le
Marig de
francetin se lever très tôt pour pouir
une
placeétaitier arriv ce projet de
consultation hebdomadaire est ent sur 2
ans en plus de limiter les déserts
médicaux dans la commune l'objectif est
aussi de convaincre les jeunes médecins
de venir exercer dans la commune financé
à hauteur de 26000 € de cout d'entrée
par l'ARS pour les équipements d'autres
projets murissent pour Pier le manque de
structure médicale dans le Nord on
travaille en ce moment même avec le
Centre Hospitalier Laurent basspointe
pour essayer de positionner dans ce
centre
hospitalier une offre de petites
urgences qui fait l'interface entre la
médecine libérale et l'urgence le
docteur Claude pe devrait débuter ses
consultation dès janvier
2024 restons solidaire avec cette
initiative de l'association Habitat et
humanisme qui a créé au moment une
escale solidaire dont le principe est
simple les personnes qui souffrent
d'isolement social peuvent venir
préparer un repas et partager un moment
de convivialité autour d'une table
Anthony pyon pour ALM TV Sart a mis le
couvert avec que
regard tout commence par l'ouverture du
frigo on regarde ce qui est disponible
quels sont les les légumes les denrées
disponibles et on décide de ce qu'on va
préparer pour le repas les produits sont
donnés à l'association Habitat et
Humanisme par la Banque alimentaire et
pour les préparatifs tout le monde met
la main à la pâte on a décidé de
faire un gâteau à la carotte ce midi à
une quiche au poireau chacun donne un
peu ses idées et puis voilà on trouve un
compromis et puis on partage les tâches
mais ce qu'on partage surtout ici c'est
le repas pour un prix de 2 € les
passagers de l'Escale solidaire ont
rendez-vous tous les lundis soirs les
mardis midi et les jeudis matins ça
m'apporte moralement j'en avais besoin
pouri voilà on essaie de garder contact
échanger les numéros et puis bah si ça
va pas qu'on s'appelle
que voilà on peut toujours se voilà il y
a toujours une
solution au problème quoi le principe
c'est celui d'un lieu de rencontre
ouvert à tous dans le but de recréer du
lien
social ceux qui sont un peu isolés
peuvent venir prendre un café se
réchauffer on est là pour
ça on travaille aussi sur la confiance
en soi l'estime de soi et pour une
réinsertion sociopressionnelle à travers
différentes activités qu'on peut
proposer et ça se termine autour d'un
repas bien chaud testé et
approuvé je vous propose maintenant
d'ouvrir une page d'histoire avec le
dernier ouvrage de Jérôme cordelier le
rédacteur en chef du service politique
du point nous livre une série de
portraits de résistants chrétiens qui
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale se sont
engagés dans la reconstruction du pays
mais aussi de l'Union européenne ils
sont français allemand ou italien et ils
ont tous relevé le défi de fonder une
Europe de la paix un message qui reste
toujours d'actualité Christophe Rigot a
rencontré l'auteur d'après la nuit
Jérôme
cordelier c'est une page d'histoire
méconnue qui a voulu mettre en lumière
Jérôme cordelier dans son dernier
ouvrage après la nuit le journaliste y
raconte le destin d'ommes et deux femmes
tous chrétiens qui à la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ont décidé de
relever la France mais aussi de
participer à la construction de l'Union
européenne des personnalités fortes
comme Robert Schuman ou Conrad adenoer
j'ai été vraiment étonné par cette
figure de Conrad adenoer qui réussit
juste a l'après guerre à
sauver l'Allemagne de de la ruine la
remettre debout et ensuite à initier
l'Europe si cet homme n'était pas habité
par une une idée qui transcende un petit
peu son son son propre cas et qui ne
soit pas seulement l'intérêt général
mais quelque chose qui est encore plus
supérieur et ben je pense qu'on aaurait
pas abouti à un tel résultat Jérôme
cordelier redonne la voix à ces
personnalités chrétiennes qui ont
fortement marqué cette époque charnière
en s'engageant en politique en économie
mais pas seulement ils sont aussi dans
le champ culturel le champ social l'abbé
Pierre lance Maus en 1949 l'abbé
vrzenssk sort lance à Téd caronde aussi
dans les mêmes
les chrétiens ils remettent la France
sur le ce ne sont pas les seuls
évidemment on me fait souvent la
réflexion en me disant est-ce que vous
pensez mais non les chrétiens n'ont pas
le monopole de de l'intérêt général il y
a beaucoup de gens évidemment qui se
sont engagés mais ils ont un rôle quand
même déterminant et je trouve qui est un
rôle qui qui qui est oublié à notre
époque après la nuit de Jérôme cordelier
est un ouvrage qui raisonne
particulièrement aujourd'hui en c'étant
troublé en nous replongeant dans
l'histoire de ceux qui qui ont posé les
fondations d'une Europe de la paix
moribon depuis 51 ans est dissimulé par
les ronces sur l'aérodrome de Castello
manoac dans les Hautes Pyrénées ce
d'assau flamand de 1953 fleuron de
l'avion militaire d'après-gerre a
retrouvé une seconde jeunesse au sud de
Toulouse chez loï Duma formateur à
l'École Nationale de l'Aviation civile
qui le garde notre partenaire La Dépêche
du Midi l'a rencontré regardez en août
2022 on parlait on connaissait cet avion
depuis 6 7 ans qui était un peu laissé
entre guillemets dans un état d'abandon
à l'aérodrome de casseno manoac et mon
ami a eu cette idée folle de dire mais
pourquoi on le sauverait pas en fait car
c'est quand même un morceau de notre
patrimoine français j'ai un peu réfléchi
je me suis dit ben pourquoi pas allons-y
il a fallu un peu d'études car on n'est
pas des professionnel du démontage
d'avion c'est la première fois qu'on
fait ça donc avec les amis et la famille
on s'y est mis partons maintenant dans
la vallée de la Morienne retrouver un
chasseur Robin et chasseur d'imagees
installé à valoir ce passionné de nature
et d'animaux a pris l'habitude
d'installer des pièges photographiques
pour capturer les images des moments
rares du quotidien de nombreuses espèces
sauvag de nos montagnes un reportage de
lucarou pour H Mont-Blanc sur
place une fois par semaine romain par à
la chasse la chasse aux belles images
originaire de Valois
ce jeune saisonnier sine les montagnes
morienaises à la recherche des animaux
sauvages et après plus d'une heure de
randonnée en raquette Robin se rapproche
de son piège photographique non sans une
certaine excitation donc je l'ai mis un
peu sur la gauche en contrebas dans des
mélaises je j'espère prendre des chamois
on verra si j'ai réussi à les prendre ou
pas et on verra aussi si on peut
apercevoir d'autres animaux sur la zone
derrière le vent chamoi chamoi écureuil
ou chamoi le piège offre une proximité
directe avec le monde sauvage c'est un
peu nos yeux qu'on pose sur les pierres
les arbres dans dans la nature et
pendant notre absence bah la faune
sauvage Suiss en cours donc on a
beaucoup de moments uniques des vrais
moments de vie des chez les animaux chez
les espèces une fois redescendu au
village Robin en profite pour jeter un
œil sur les nombreux clichés qu'il a
glané depuis 7 ans
ser chamois ou marmotte les animaux
capturés sont nombreux et c'est quand il
ne s'attend à pas grand-chose que Robin
est le plus souvent surpris j'ai mis mon
piège en été j'étais pressé je l'avais
mal mis j'étais pas content de moi je me
suis dit j'en suis sûr que je prendrai
rien et c'est quand un coup je suis allé
le récupérer j'ai vu une image et dans
ma tête je me suis dit c'est pas un chot
c'est pas un Renardo c'est quoi et j'ai
mis la vidéo d'après j'ai vu qu'il y
avait de lfto qui était passé devant
donc voilà ça arrivait qu'une fois pour
l'instant et peut-être que ça arrivera
un jour désormais Robin souhaiterait
cacher ses pièges photographiques plus
haut en altitude là où la vie sauvage
reste encore la plus
inconnue depuis de nombreuses années
nadine chomara est une passionnée de
santon tous les ans dans son village de
Périgneux dans la Loire elle installe
une crèche pour les fêtes bien sûr cette
année la crèche de Nadine et de ses
enfants occupe 10 m² du salon familial
une véritable œuvre d'art remplie de
petits détails que nous fait découvrir
Céline Ilia pour
TL7 on va mettre les petites chèvres là
Jaffard tu me donnes de la mousse s'il
te plaît il ne reste que quelques jours
pour terminer le tableau alors tout le
monde met la main à la patte la crèche
c'est une histoire de famille pour
Nadine chomara elle a pris la passion de
sa maman pour les santon et a agrandi sa
collection chaque année elle change
toutes les scénettes de sa crèche000 408
pièces sans compter les détails
fabriqués maison tout est pensé dans le
moindre détail elle aime observer la
nature et reproduire ce qu'elle voit ça
a été un défi un peu de mettre l'eau la
vraiment l'eau cette année parce que on
narrêtait pas de me dire et alors elle
court pas l'eau elle court pas donc pour
l'instant on a fait le le fleuve
j'allais dire l'eau qui descend de la
montagne et peut-être que l'année
prochaine on aura l'eau qui court
carrément jusqu'à la mer la crèche est
réalisée dans un esprit traditionnel le
côté religieux y est aussi présent on y
voit les rois mages mais aussi Marie et
Joseph qui vont se déplacer dans la
crèche jourg et ben on mettra tout le
monde dans la crèche avec le petit Jésus
c'est vrai que ça a une connotation
religieuse he la crèche mais il y a
aussi un beau rassemblement avec les
nations puisqueon a quand même ces trois
les Trois Rois Mages qui viennent
apporter des offrandes au petit Jésus du
traditionnel qui n'empêche pas quelques
notes d'humour comme ce personnage très
recherché chez parnadine elle s'appelle
le kagadou donc c'est un petit
personnage qui fait caca dans la nature
ça fait bien 8 ans que j'essaie d'en
acheter un parce que c'est tellement
prisé on va dire que du
coup on le trouve pas tout le temps la
crèche devrait être terminée pour le 1er
décembre une œuvre qui ne reste pas dans
le simple cadre familial chaque année
plusieurs personnes viennent la
découvrir les enfants auront pour
mission de retrouver certains animaux
dans le décor les santons devraient
rester installés jusqu'à fin
février avant de nous quitter je vous
propose de découvrir le marché de Noël
de Limoge ainsi que le spectacle de son
et lumière projeté sur l'église
Saint-Pierre du kerrois sur des images
de Tom Capron pour cette
[Musique]
halimoge voilà et puis c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires au revoir à
[Musique]
tous